at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
well hey everybody what's going on do
you think the lights too bright or do
you like it it looks pretty good to me I
think yeah okay
what does everybody else think I mean
I'm not really sure they can drop it in
the comment section because it's like it
looks it looks good on my end but I
don't know what it looks like
everything looks better when you use
your glasses are you gonna put on I'll
put on my ladies so I can see this
sexy I'm all sophisticated
of course I can't see now so I don't
really yeah it looks good okay that's
good yeah I spiraled through all the
colors and it's like I like some of the
colors but I didn't think you would like
them
Zach says y'all look good very Supple
and flesh-like
just like Tom Hardy's ass let's not go
down that route again y'all girls talk
about Tom Hardy's ass man well I was
just kind of amazed by the by the angle
you know what that old back arch
yeah Zach says it's still weird seeing
Jen without glasses yeah and the weird
thing is like I said I only wear them
you know to look at computers and to
read yeah because I think it doesn't
have them I can see normally but I can't
see like close up because I'm old so
that's why uh but yeah so I'm kind of I
think this will be kind of a fun show
because it doesn't I'm not gonna have
like any kind of big structure or
anything like that but I've been wanting
to do a show just kind of like
freewheeling talking about the weekly
world news like for a while and so I'm
glad that that finally won in the poll
by an overwhelming margin so like I said
I kind of feel like this is gonna be
like not so structured and just kind of
like a free willing show because people
can
think about what their what their
favorite weekly world news [__]
headlines were and if you're not from
the United States I don't know like how
much the weekly world news is known
outside of the US it's a very American
thing and I kind of feel like it was
probably it's published in Florida
and I kind of feel like if Florida man
was a newspaper then the weekly world
news would be that newspaper like it's
online only now you can't get the print
thing anymore they stop printing it in I
think 2007. they stopped wasting paper
they stopped wasting paper on it but um
well some people collected I was
watching a YouTube video earlier today
like on my lunch hour of a guy who like
collects some of them so he has like
some of the old and it's funny because I
had some of those back in the day too
because yeah it was only like a quarter
or 50 cents like back in the old days
like in the 90s so if it had like a
funny headline then you would just like
buy it and read all the crazy [__] in
there but I think people mostly people
remember them for the crazy headlines
yeah Jenny's got them printed out I have
some that I've printed out that I just
thought were that one right there I
remember that as a kid well that boy I
mean that boy is the most he's almost
like their mascot at this point they
first came up with batboy in 1992. and
if you don't know who batboy is he's
kind of like he's supposedly she's gonna
show you he was a half man half bat or
half boy half that like kid right yeah
and he was allegedly found in a cave in
West Virginia
and the first story was yeah the first
story I think was bat child found in
cave or something like that like in the
90s and then like as time went on that
um that character was so popular that
they would keep doing recurring stories
about it where eventually like he worked
with special forces like he went into
outer space
um and he did like all kind of like like
he went to capture himself Bin Laden
this wasn't no this was actually after
this was um when did they first unleash
Bad Boys 92 92 that's what I said 92
yeah but this article isn't from 92 this
is the later one because like I said he
kind of became a recurring character and
did all kind of crazy I can't believe
that that was so recent I thought that
because I remembered it but I thought I
was remembering that from like the early
80s no I mean weekly world news has been
around since 1979. okay but batboy
didn't come about until 1992 because
that [__] was iconic I remember seeing
that yeah I think it was their second
biggest selling issue which is why they
kept
putting the character like in more
scenarios yeah and Oracle said there's a
musical about batboy it's Bonkers yeah
there's a musical about it and there's
also um a comic strip about it where he
does like even crazy or [__] because I
mean the thing about weekly world news
you know it comes out weekly and the
people that work there I mean it's
obviously
not meant to be taken seriously and I
kind of feel like their whole aesthetic
is it supposed to look as cheap Jack and
shitty as possible so it's like they
don't so I think it's kind of a thing
where it's like well they don't really
have a lot of time to do like a really
good Photoshop that looks realistic
because a lot of the stuff looks really
janky but in a way that kind of like
contributes to its charm I guess because
what they're doing is they were kind of
homaging the National Enquirer because
well it's the same it's the same uh
publication company but Inquirer would
do that but it would be a little bit
more believable in The Enquirer a little
bit not a whole lot but you know like
inquire would show you a photograph of a
[__] stain on a ceiling that looked
like Jesus
you know yeah and they're like oh Jesus
appears in the [__]
toilet bowl stain or whatever is that
you Jesus gross Jesus Jesus appears on a
[__] piece of [__] toast you know
the way the toast Burn Right Jesus face
and [__] you know I haven't [__] like it
might have been slightly touched up but
it was you know yeah it looked okay I
have a thing it's like it's a plastic uh
it looks like a cookie cutter and what
you do and it has Jesus on it is it
Jesus is the Virgin Mary I think it has
Jesus on it and it's it was specifically
made to put into a into toast into bread
and then you put it in there when it
toasts it comes out it looks like it has
Jesus on it yeah I wonder what happened
to that it's around here somewhere but
yeah it did make some Jesus toast with
it a couple of times but that's the well
you know what's funny
speaking of Jesus like in the in the uh
in the toast and everything I was on my
way home from work today I was listening
to a podcast which wasn't entirely about
the weekly world news but it was kind of
like a lot about it because one of the
guys that was on there it was just two
guys talking and one of the guys used to
work there like he was the editor
and he had actually come from National
Lampoon and he started working there in
1999 and was kind of like made the boss
and he's just like I you know he's like
yeah I'd worked for humor magazines but
this was like a whole different
kind of vibe to it
and he was saying that it's like so we
have this huge repository of photos like
of various kinds and we would buy photos
like from people if they called up and
had something that we thought sounded
cool and he's like so he was telling the
story like this woman called and said oh
I have a picture of like Jesus like in a
cloud or something and he's like big
[__] deal we have like a million
pictures of Jesus in the clouds or Jesus
in a piece of pizza or whatever the [__]
and she's like yeah but this one's a
little bit different and he's like well
what's different about it she's like
well there's another guy in the cloud
with Jesus and he's like oh who's the
other guy Karl Marx he was like send
that [__] right over you know what I
mean so it was like that kind of thing
it's like when I was um reading like all
about weekly world news like there's a
very famous quote which is attached to
it I don't think it's the same guy that
said this but one of the um news that it
actually might have been because I
didn't catch his name but one of his
quotes about it uh about the weekly
world news said if someone calls me up
and says their toaster is talking to
them I don't refer them to professional
how I say put the toaster on the phone
so that's like pretty much what you're
but you know what's interesting as I was
kind of delving into
um the background of of this honestly
like a lot of the stories yeah some of
the stories particularly later on
because I think in 1999 I think was when
they got a new owner
and he just um and he hired a bunch of
comedy writers like I said he got the
the editor guy from National Lampoon and
he recruited people from like comedy
Publications to kind of like punch it up
and make it funnier but um prior to that
he's like you you might think that most
of the stories were just like completely
made up out of whole cloth and he's like
and some of them were like especially
later but he's like most of them
actually did have a germ of Truth to
them he's like what we would do
especially in the early days is we had
we would get papers from all over the
world like newspapers and so the writers
and stuff would just go through piles
and piles of papers like every single
day like looking for weird ass stories
like from around the world and then they
would find like a germ of something that
sounded weird and then they would
embellish the [__] out of it so he's
like so most of the stories that you saw
on there is outlandish as they were did
actually have some like a tiny tiny
kernel of Truth they usually weren't
completely made of like and for an
example of that he's like now this one
didn't get printed because he's like
here here's the funny thing too is that
in their offices which I think are Boca
Raton and he's like that explains a lot
yeah well that's what I said this is
like the publication uh equivalent of
Florida man yeah and uh and he was kind
of saying a similar sort of thing too
and he's like because he was from La you
know what I mean so he's just like he
thought he's like yeah it's Florida yeah
it was a little weird Florida is a fun
place it's out of here well I don't know
it's it's a weird place Florida and
that's kind of what he was saying yeah
but you know it has its own um thing it
has its own thing going on so he said
um he's like so the publication for a
long time he's like and this might
surprise you too but he's like it had we
had a quonset hut
with like 50 lawyers in there like they
all had their own desk and everything
and it's like whenever you anybody that
wrote a story you had to take it to all
the lawyers and they had to like vet it
and make sure they didn't get sued
because like the new owner was like if
you got a lawsuit like then you got
fired like immediately so you really had
to be careful that you had to like kind
of skirt around stuff and he's like so
there's this one story and he's like and
I wanted to do it but um the lawyers
wouldn't let him do it he's like so he
knew you know the actress
um Natasha hadstridge she was in species
and okay and all that that woman the
woman the woman from species yeah and
he's like so he knew her and it's like
and she told me this story but this is
what he said he said while she was
filming some movie I don't remember what
one it was it wasn't species but she's
like there was a there was a incident
where she was supposed to be swimming
with a dolphin and the dolphin like
dragged her under the water and like
spun her around and essentially like
tried to rape her like the dolphin did
which I said yeah dolphins are kind of
actually it was a poor purpose but you
know same difference so yeah dolphins
and porpoises are very rapey animals in
case anybody's in it now but so he was
gonna run with this story but he had
like this crazy headline to like pull
people in because it was like you know
alien gets sexually assaulted by
dolphins or something like that because
she played an alien in the movie you
know what I mean and then he was going
to run with that but the lawyers
wouldn't let him do it and they said
well after a while because the National
Enquirer which was their sister paper
that was the one with all the celebrity
gossip and all that crazy kind of [__]
so it was like we very very rarely
printed celebrity stories this was
usually like regular
Joe's and and like I said they had a
recurring list it wasn't just batboy
they had like some other characters too
that like um there was one who was an
alien
named pilad he was calling him plot at
first but he's like no now that I think
about it he's like that you know I had
to write stories about this alien
because that's what you did he was like
a recurring character but he's like he
had started like before I got there and
this alien
um they had kind of a big thing like in
the 90s where he was like dating Hillary
Clinton and then
um him and Bill Clinton got in a fight
and it was like I think I have that that
uh issue in here somewhere with like but
when it has like a picture of Bill
Clinton was somebody like a photoshopped
black guy and it's like and then they
got in a fight over Hillary and all this
other kind of stuff so there was like a
whole thing about
pilot he was like another he was another
recurring character and not just and
then they had this other guy that was
like a super super fat guy named what's
his name simkit Buster Sim kiss or
something like that and there was a
bunch of stories about him the funniest
ones about the funniest one about him
was that they were gonna
they were gonna lower him down into the
like whenever this was whenever the
Super Bowl I think was in New Orleans I
don't remember what year that was and
they said they were going to lower him
down like a blimp so they could put like
advertising all over him because he was
like super fat so yeah so
so that was another recurring character
that did not exist I guess right no no
they just made them up made them up and
the thing about the thing of it was
funny too he's like when you see um
because even he was in some of the
pictures too because he's like if you
see a picture of like you know FBI agent
does this that and the other thing it's
like usually just one of us or somebody
in the office would go and like put on a
suit and go out in the parking lot and
like take a picture because it was
weekly so you needed to like get this
[__] done like right away yeah so he's
like so he's like I was in some of the
pictures he's like you know the
secretaries were inside but nobody
noticed that it's the same people all
over probably not I mean there's one I
have one in here too with it was another
one with uh Bill Clinton that said he
hired a three breasted intern yeah and
um you can do that yeah and well the
funniest thing about that is that it
also has like a little thing of Hillary
over there like with a shocked face and
it said I thought he was a leg man which
I thought was very funny but um but yes
they said the three breasted woman that
was just like she didn't have three
breasts obviously but um she's like yeah
that was just some girl that worked in
the office and they were like hey can we
take a picture of you and like
and I guess she was like she's like
that's just what they did like they just
did this [__] like every day like they
had to go out and like mock up all these
[__]
we've got a lot of all the regulars are
in yeah yeah
oracle's in John
Hugo mr88 hey everybody
yeah
John goris said anyone see the Johnny
Carson show
yeah everybody's here everybody's here
where his guest has a potato chip with
Christ's image on it and as a goof
Carson eats it oh not the actual chip
but a stunt one and she freaked out yeah
yeah
that's pretty good I mean that is pretty
funny you popped the other one and eight
yeah my cheese is cheap
Jesus not a pringle oh my God that's
[__] hilarious but yeah it's so I
don't know I I do kind of feel like the
the the overarching thing of the weekly
world news like I said I I feel like
most people in the United States know
what it is it was its Heyday was in the
90s I feel like the 80s and 90s and then
its circulation kind of started to
decline I think at its height the
circulation was like 1.2 million or
something like that which is a lot and
after that it kind of started to decline
just like a you know the rest of print
media did and so in 2007 they just
totally went online and it's still there
like most of the Articles like you can
go to weeklyworldnews.com and they have
all the [__] in there but um I think
it's behind a paywall now I think you
can read three articles for free and
then you gotta subscribe and I don't
know how much the subscription is but
they still have [__] hilarious
headlines so I'm sure that like [__]
I think I wrote some down like in here
didn't I didn't I write some down that
said something about like the Easter
Bunny Union or some [__] like that yeah
uh Airlines to offer outdoor seating
that was one that I liked yes
yeah I liked that one oh yeah Easter
Bunny Union cancels Easter deliveries I
thought that was funny too and then it
had like a picture of somebody like in a
bunny suit like going or you know what I
mean which I thought was kind of
hilarious and then there was kind of
there was one today that they put up
about like goat yoga or something but
yeah
and then like some other ones were like
alien Bible found they worship Oprah
oh this was one of my favorites too
second pope under Pope hat there's
another one yeah okay and it's just like
just the visual of that also severed leg
hops to hospital I thought that was
pretty funny too but yeah so that I mean
I I've said before many times I think my
very favorite
uh weekly world news headline was
chocoholic mom gives birth to
sugar-coated baby like I don't know why
that tickled me so much but it did
although severed leg cops the hospital
that's pretty good too and second pope
under popat but yeah
I wonder how the article's actually read
what they did
um yeah usually most people I think most
people probably didn't even read them
they were just because they just like
the headlines but um what they would do
and this was Again part of their
he was the guy was talking about it like
on the on the show today and he was like
we were supposed to write the Articles
as if they were true it's like obviously
they weren't but you had to and he's
like but the weird thing about it is
that it had the paper had its own kind
of like language to it in its own like
syntax and um he's like it was kind of
old-fashioned in a way like a lot of the
words they used and [__] like that
because you know I was thinking about
how you know Mad Magazine like had their
own little like you know recurring words
yeah phrases they would use and [__]
like that so it's that kind of thing
right and he's like but you were
supposed to
write it just like a regular news story
as if even though as outlandish as it
was you were supposed to rate it exactly
like it was a real news story and for a
long time too because you know how a lot
of parody
um things and I don't even know if
there's what the legality is about this
but you know a lot of parody news was
like the onion and things like that you
know it'll say even if it's in tiny tiny
fine print that it's like you know this
is a parody
like bloody blah but for a long time the
weekly world news didn't have that I
think in 2004 they started putting a
message like this is you know for
entertainment only or something like
that so I don't know if they got in some
kind of trouble but and like I said I'm
not entirely sure what the legality of
that is I mean I'm pretty sure that you
can get in trouble for printing [__]
that's not true and printing it as if
it's true but I guess it depends on what
it is and if somebody's gonna like sue
you about it like you can't just
you know obviously you can't just like
say random [__] about people without
saying like allegedly and you can't like
say it as if it's true like they can sue
you but like I said but they got away
with it for a long time I guess because
the thing about weekly world news is I
feel like even though most of the
stories were supposedly like based on a
kernel of Truth at least I think that
the perception was that it was so
outlandish that no one would actually
believe it was real even though some of
the some of the stories in there were
actually true like there was one
um in there that I think took place in
Florida actually was Florida or Georgia
and it was called and it said Hogzilla
it was just like about this giant like
crazy hog that was running a muck and
everything and it's like that that was
true that was I remember that yeah yeah
yeah so that was true I mean it was
exaggerated a little bit but that wasn't
[__] that's even better with cement
guava juice in it you want some
um sure I guess so yeah
although I will note
that some of the stories that weren't
quite as out there
um as far as like because it does stick
a lot to like Paranormal stuff like
aliens and Bigfoot and
um Armageddon type stuff like out of the
world like biblical prophecies
Nostradamus
um Elvis is alive that kind of [__] like
it keeps to that but it's some of the
stuff that's in there is just like crazy
news stories like you know like a dude
that got struck by lightning seven times
or something like that because they were
always like looking for
it's almost like news of the weird in
that way you know what I'm saying so
some of this stuff wasn't as crazy but
then as it went on I guess they just
leaned into
and then they just started coming up
with [__] crazy [__] you know what I
mean
um
High Desert 0404 said uh I think
everyone has at least one relative who
believed that [__] was real yeah it's
like I might be giving people too much
credit
um I will note that one story that I
know was reported as true at least once
was there was a story which technically
isn't that crazy I mean it's kind of
crazy but it's not like you know Elvis
is alive and living on the moon crazy
but there was a story in there about I
think it was the LAPD and that they had
supposedly spent a billion dollars on
jet packs for their entire uh force and
Fox and Friends reported it as though it
was true and we're like all outraged
about it and it's like um that was from
the weekly world news you Dim bulbs so
yeah but I mean like I said obviously
it's a crazy story but it's not as crazy
as them reporting jpegs yeah but I mean
Hey where's my jet pack a billion
dollars on jet pack so they can like fly
around it's not that unusual if you
understand American history anyway their
freedom of the press
um
a newspaper could write whatever it
wanted they still can
um but there's like I said there's some
legal [__] you know you can't do slander
and things but you can pretty much write
whatever you want and um
throughout the 1800s 1700s they did they
just made [__] up at a whole clock yeah
they did not give it singles it's called
yellow journalism and it never stopped
they just make they they will just
they'll say anything you can pay them
even today to write an article that
favors your company or whatever they're
they're mercenaries if you pay them
enough they'll write an article about
you
I knew something was crazy one time
this is back in the 2000s I looked at a
newspaper
and the story was about how great a
Saudi oil prince was
and that he's a businessman and he's
coming to America
and I'm I'm reading this thing I'm going
man this is like a paid advertisement
and I went this is a paid advertisement
this dude paid to get this article I
never heard of that dude again
well yeah and it's I mean it's pretty
common nowadays like now you're kind of
supposed to disclose it's like yeah I'm
writing my I'm writing an article or a
review of this product or whatever but
it's like you have to disclose or you're
supposed to disclose it's like oh they
sent me a free one or they paid me for
the endorsement or something like that
like even YouTube videos you're supposed
to Mark if it has like a like an
Advertiser or like a paid uh
advertisement in there yeah because you
know they do try to integrate it
with um because some of the YouTube
channels I watch like that like Jade the
Libra and
um and Brian Hollinger and stuff like
that they have sponsors but they
integrate the stuff into their
show so it's not like a commercial
commercial necessarily but it's just
them talking about the product but yeah
they always have to like put it has all
the stuff around the outside but that's
the thing we I mean I used to work for
newspapers so yeah what you would do if
you had a company in the town
that paid you a bunch of money and like
paid for a big huge advertisement then
you could you know then they'd have
somebody write a puff piece about them
or they would send you something like
from their PR department like to print
somewhere near the ad you know what I
mean but you had to put on it
um underneath you had to put paid
advertising or they had to put like a
little some kind of blurb like
underneath to say it's like hey they
paid for this right for this uh
you know this article brown-nosing or
whatever it was
so they did at least do that but that's
about all I know
um
Oracle says oh hey it was our
anniversary last week and I made your
Thai red curry again Tom Turner great
yeah yeah which car which spice mix did
you use the uh
I guess the red one the red one the red
one in the damn can yeah
probably the yellow one's my favorite
but they're all good they're all good
the green one yeah the purple one the
pandan Curry oh that's good man all
those little Indonesian [__] curries
mixes I like that pin anchoring that's
really yeah you can make that stuff you
can make that you could it's just garlic
and a bunch of spices turned into a pan
yeah I mean you know it's just easier to
get it's just easier to get out a can
but yeah
um somebody mentioned redneck vampire
attacks trailer park and matter of fact
that's one of the ones that I have here
this these are great because some of the
[__] like okay so for example they do a
lot of stuff about like presidential
like uh candidates you said it was the
red curry paste yeah okay
so this is like uh Obama appoints
Martian Ambassador right there but
sometimes I feel like the funnier [__]
is like look flying cats terrorize West
Virginia who knew and also I really like
this one wife shrinks cheating husband
keeps him in a jar okay yeah see so I
kind of like that right there so he's
like that to me that should be like the
whole headline because that's like way
funnier that's way fun and they're like
nah this happens all the time
what somebody's shrinking their [__]
yeah that's like that's pretty awesome
though I just really like the wife
shrinking the cheating and this one too
oh here's the three breasted intern
see I mean look at so that was somebody
that girl there that somebody I think
that worked at the weekly World News
offices and they just like took that's a
pretty good that's a pretty good
Photoshop I gotta say like of the three
brass like for you know for it being
like really quick but like I said I
thought it was a leg man I thought that
was really funny oh and also Edgar Casey
reincarnated as psychic fly
so there's that too the Buzz for two for
2002.
oh my God
you like that I can barely see are you
gonna oh yeah I thought I didn't know
it's just some girl I didn't necessarily
want to show you that because then
you're gonna like make me get a third
breast no you don't think yeah I know so
I don't know two's enough you think
plenty
I like this there's there's the one
about the about the alien fight also
look at this inside get a sex change
free yeah inside inside the newspaper
just open it and it'll get a sex change
wow that's wow that's amazing I think
they worded that not so good yeah
let me see what else I got here Bigfoot
challenge that's just like
news reporter eaten alive by 80 foot
dinosaur which is clearly an iguana yeah
that's pretty good though I like the
little dude yeah they're homage in the
50s monsters yeah yeah that's what I
think it's like Beats from 20 000
fathoms yeah although that wasn't an
iguana that was actually like a ray
harryhausen but yeah I like that one
here
yeah
Brazilian jungle it's a monitor oh now
this one this might this might be my new
favorite I don't know why this is so
funny to me
mini mermaid found in tuna sandwich what
I asked for extra mayo and got this says
Iowa man and then look at his [__]
face and he's pulling for some reason
like right around this time period which
I don't know when this was
like I can't see when the what the date
was because it's too blurry but they
went on kind of like a mermaid tear and
for some reason it wasn't just mermaids
either like they particularly liked like
miniature mermaids and Merman
which I don't really know I guess like
everybody just thought that was a funny
idea and it hadn't been done because the
comic books man the little sea monkeys I
guess so yeah when was that when did
that mermaid documentary come out
the one that your dad thought was real
yeah that was true
I don't know
sometimes also this is funny too but
it's like like I said just the smaller
ones here who left beer cans on the moon
and apparently I didn't see the inside
of this but like the guy that was um
that was talking on YouTube he said um
that that was like a whole spread where
they just had like pictures of the Moon
and they like you know obviously
photoshopped beer cans on there but I
think what was funny to that is like I
liked the accusatory tone of it like
it's not there's beer cans on the moon
it's who left beer cans like who [__]
did this like that's very funny to me so
it's like whoever is like writing these
this I feel like this would be a really
fun job
I mean the guy that was talking is like
he didn't really like it because he's
like look I came from National Lampoon
he was more like a big city guy and he's
like National Lampoon was more I get
he's like it was kind of more like
highbrow humor where it's like this is
kind of like lowest common denial he's
like it's kind of like wrestling yeah
he's like is basically what it is
um he's like so it was fun for a while
and he's like actually the pay was
incredible and they even like gave him a
condo and like all this other kind of
[__] but um and he had a driver and like
a car and everything and he's like so
that was pretty sweet but he's like you
know I didn't really he's like I didn't
really love it I didn't really love
having to do that and he's like and I
wasn't used to working for a weekly you
know because you really had to like do
everything really quickly obviously
because National Lampoon was monthly a
month in publication and um you know
working for a weekly or actually I
worked at a weekly newspaper and a daily
newspaper and say you just have to like
you don't have time to do anything you
just you have to get everything out like
super super fast like all the time and
it's kind of like that so he's like
that's why whenever we would make up
this story and like you go in with the
50 lawyers and the Kwanzaa hut and then
they would tell you that the story was
okay and then you had to go and shoot
some photos he's like now we did have a
huge you know what they would call a
morgue like in newspaper parlance of
that's usually where they keep like all
the old newspapers but he said we had
this huge photo library so it's like so
a lot of times if you were doing a story
about Bigfoot or you know about aliens
doing whatever and it's like and you
needed a picture of something like a
random FBI agent or something like that
it's like we had a [__] ton of pictures
like that so it's like you had to just
go and like find it because I guess
everything was filed but he's like
sometimes we didn't have any of that and
you would have to take one and he said
too that he worked there in
uh 2001 like after 9 11. and he's like
and you remember after that there was
like that anthrax scare and he's like
some of the anthrax was sent to the
National Enquirer and like I think that
guy died like that worked there
and he's like so the National Enquirer
and weekly world news were like sister
Publications he's like so all of our
photos were like in this building and
there was like Anthrax in there and he's
like and so we couldn't go in there like
to get any of the folks because they
just had it all taped off and he's like
and so for months and months like nobody
would come and like clean out the
anthrax because you needed like the team
to come and he's like so we kept like
who the guy that owned weekly world news
at the time he's like he kept
petitioning like Jeb Bush who was the
governor or whatever then and he's like
and he wouldn't come and like he
wouldn't allow anybody to like come
clean it up for like a really long time
so it's like they couldn't go in and get
any of their photos because it was like
[__] Anthrax and he's like so it
became kind of a running joke after a
while where it's like hey what's you
know how bad can Anthrax be go in there
and get some of the photos you know what
I mean because it's like they couldn't
go in there because it was all they
[__] taped off but it's like yeah it
was like he had all kind of like [__]
crazy stories about this place but it
was just really funny to listen to It's
on YouTube Somewhere I can't remember
what it's called but this one too uh see
this like I said the what he was saying
about this being like super low Brown
like wrestling I mean our toilet is
haunted by a plumber's ghost
family flipping its lid over potty
Poltergeist see so that's kind of like
the
it's kind of you know it's very juvenile
but like I said that's what I think
that's what endeared it to people I mean
because some of the [__] see I like
this one too
surgeons cut my head off and sewed it
back on you know I hate when that
happens so I don't know what the story
behind that is but it's like I don't
know if there was like some [__] ring
of Truth to that but
and uh this one
fat cat owns 23 old ladies damn that was
another I think this was another
recurring character this big huge fat
cat now the fat cat was real like it was
this big huge cat I think it weighed 80
pounds or something and which is a very
fat cat but people responded so well to
this cat that they kept putting the cat
in like new adventures
yeah so they would do like yeah so like
if somebody responded really well to
like a character like the fat guy like
you know being lowered into the stadium
or what or batboy or whatever then they
would just keep making up stories about
because I mean batboy he went on a whole
[__] thing man like I said he joined
Special Forces like he would keep
getting captured by scientists and then
he would escape and like doctor's
autopsy a ghost yeah yeah yeah oh and
this one this this is great too and it's
like I said it's just down at the bottom
I didn't even notice it at first parrot
vanishes during peek-a-boo game
which I was like that's [__] awesome
I just you know what I mean it's like
you don't even have to read the stories
you don't have to read the stories
because that [__] is [__] hilarious
but uh yeah duck hunter shoot Angel
there's that one wow yeah look at that
that's look that is like that is very
that is very bad what is that I could do
like it's supposed to be an angel
but look it looks like oh okay yeah
okay
somebody in a damn Hospital [__] gown
yeah with like some wings [__] like
kind of it doesn't even look like oh
they're floating in the in the lake oh
okay I couldn't figure that out it's in
the lake yeah let's see like she's
different I got face down in the lid
because I'm sitting there going what the
[__] is the deal with that why does she
look like she's just like stiff out like
that I guess she's just like laying in
the [__]
Oracle says Jan in the band I that's
what I thought too that was um did you
say have you seen that MST episode uh
uh it wasn't the head that couldn't die
that was a different movie it was um the
[__] is the name of that movie I just
totally [__] spaced out on it it's
about this guy and he's like a scientist
and he's
um his fiance is in the car damn and she
they get in a wreck and she gets
beheaded and he keeps the head alive oh
yeah yeah with with this special juice
yeah I remember that and then he goes
around like looking for a new body so
it's kind of like a Proto Man with Two
Brains except it's a whole head and
she's like not happy about it I mean she
just does not and so when they did it on
MST they called her Jan in the pan and
actually Mary Jo peel like you know who
plays Mrs Forrester she was actually a
recurring character like she would BJ
into the pan so she would be just let's
just like this head in a [__] like
metal baking dish or something like that
like with all these [__] but yeah it
was like super funny that's what that
was actually Mike Mike's first uh
episode and it's still one of my
favorite ones that's still like really
[__] funny to me
um aliens abduct cheerleaders
so look she's like with the bra That's
like [__] funny Santa arrested while
checking who's naughty I don't know how
that happened
but yeah here's the redneck vampire
attacks trailer park one
like with his [__] teeth coming out
like that
Dr cures all phobias
and then ete School yearbook Discovery
they're like an alien
they clearly did somebody's nose and
foot like some [__] on them and then
there's like batboy and stuff like that
but yeah so those are like just some of
the good ones that I saw I think that
too the mini mermaid and the [__]
tuna sandwich was like the funniest
[__] thing yeah my dad actually uh
what year was that did he that's what I
can't remember it was around the brain
that wouldn't die thank you it was like
2017 Maybe 2016.
me and Jim were getting ready for a show
and I was talking my dad on the phone
and he's like yeah there's all kinds of
weird stuff he goes like some of that
stuff I didn't think it was real then it
turned out it was real like like
mermaids and I was like what here wait
what mermaids are real mermaids
well then the saw this program
and it gives a whole history of them
thousands of years people were seeing
them
and it's on cave paintings and up in the
they got drones inside the pyramid
and it turns out
turns out they're real they got they got
they got mermaids and mermaid down there
I didn't think that [__] was real and I
was like no no and he goes yeah yeah it
was on History Channel I thought on a TV
yeah
the head arm scientists they're down
there
I was like wait a minute hold on what
the [__] is this and I was trying to get
the name of this all right I said hold
on I'm gonna check that I'm gonna look
into this Dad I'm gonna look into this
yeah yeah she doesn't have internet yeah
he's still living like his [__] 1984.
so I um
I told Jen about it
and Jen looked into it on the internet
and came back like five minutes later oh
yeah that was a that was uh something
from the Discovery Channel it's a
mockumentary it's a mockumentary it
looked like it's a real documentary you
know but it was for Monster week or
something yeah yeah and
then like a History Channel or Discovery
or something bought it
and they ran it
and Boomers you know the boomer
generation if it's on TV it's real
that's just that's the thinking if you
have some authority figures some doctors
or something to tell you something oh
that's that's true
and it was he doesn't he didn't know
what a mockumentary was
yeah that's and he goes no it's not that
it was a real documentary and it says no
it's called a mockumentary it's supposed
to be like a real documentary yeah and
it goes the the doctors that they had on
there were all actors
and and it took me a while to convince
him because once a person's duped it's
hard to undoop them and as you know I
was I was kind of curious about wild and
female doctors were fine as hell like
that you know
that's what that's what that was what
that was the one thing that made him
suspicious is that the female doctors
were too hot they were too hot yeah
they were too hot that's typical
[Laughter]
don't see that
that's a bridge too far bridge too far
and
um I went that's hilarious I went and
looked at the duck we watched the
documentaries me and we watched it and
when the when the female side just came
on I was like oh that's what my dad's
talking about yeah she looked like she
looked like a damn fashion model or a
porn star or something it was a good
mockumentary but you could tell that
they were actors yeah I mean you know
they were too young a lot of the people
and the CGI wasn't great I thought no I
mean it was okay for something that was
probably not didn't have that high of a
budget but I mean you know coming from
someone who you know people that are
into horror movies and stuff like that I
mean we've seen tons and tons of
mockumentaries so it's just kind of like
I'm like yeah that's pretty good but
[__] man troll Hunter was a you should
show him troll Hunter and maybe he'll
think giant trolls are real also you see
he got me on one he he he had this this
is when it was before I joined the army
and uh
he goes here I want you to read this man
this is this is some serious [__] here
this is so serious yeah this is a good
book
so what's it about it's about these
Vikings and they go fight these
Neanderthals
I was like what you're like wait what
those things weren't around at the same
time yeah
so and and it was a book it was called
Eaters of the Eaters of the Dead yeah
and it's
a mockumentary on book it does sound
authentic uh they're telling this story
and a guy who's like a historian or I
don't remember he's an anthropologist
he's
reading that he he's says he has this
book and he's gonna print some of it and
it's uh and it was a book that was
found in Iraq written in um Arabic by
some dude named IBN fadland was his name
and that he'd spent time with the
with the Vikings
he was up there trying to spread Islam
or something with him it didn't work and
while they were there they've got it
attacked
by some Savages
and turns out over time you know he's
they cut an arm off he's looking he's
never seen an arm like that because he
was an educated Arab Guy this is like
the year I don't know 1200 or something
and they have this big war with these
cannibals
and he eventually sees them and he
describes them and the way he describes
him is Neanderthal they were living in a
cave
and they went down there to go kill him
and then it's then it says this is where
the book ends and then there's a big
thing like we think what they're talking
about is this and that but it was a
mockumentary they made a book they made
a movie about it called what was it 13th
Warrior yeah yeah the 13th Warrior is a
retelling of a book called Eaters of the
Dead
that's what I mean if you like
historical fiction that's what you call
it mockumentaries
um or you know what we would call
mockumentaries or things like um args
things like that like the way that it's
formatted is different but it's like
it's not new that's not a new phenomenon
like people have been doing
you know making art that they wanted to
like seem like it was real for like a
really long time I feel like for a long
time it was usually like novels you know
so you have like even Dracula is written
like that
I don't think anybody thought like
Dracula was true but he wrote it as
though yeah it was like news stories and
letters and journal entries and things
like that and so like I said it's not so
in a way that's kind of like an ARG
would be today where you're making
videos it's like this is a real thing
that happened you know or this is a real
thing that I found or whatever where
you're trying to make it as realistic as
possible yeah well my dad read that book
he thought it was real he gave it to me
and I read it and I thought it was I
thought it was real yeah it wasn't until
a lot later
when that movie came out I heard about
that movie I said well it sounds like
that book
that I read
it turned out it was that book and if
that book was a fiction yeah I thought
it was real but it was a fiction well do
you remember when we did a show a long
time ago because you told me to look
into this thing that you had read about
like because it's like you know the um
Bill witch no no it wasn't Bell Witch it
was um like four like four 40 in uh
archeology like people like people
finding live frogs that were like
thousands of years old like encased in
rocks and yeah
um you said something about like um
pterodactyls like in a cave like in a
stalactite or something like that and so
I was looking into it and it turned out
that that was also a fictional story
that had been written as though it was
real okay and they wrote it like a
newspaper story and it got published in
a newspaper so some people did believe
that it was real but then they turned
out later that it wasn't it's a long
history of bullshitting people
well you know it's it's fun it's fun
yeah
well that's what the Bell Witch story
people uh I read about that and that
that seemed like something that really
happened
and the phenomena sounded like
Poltergeist with a bunch of other stuff
in there that I'd never seen before with
the Poltergeist case
but um
late much later with the Advent of the
internet
you're able to check and check and see
where these stories came from
and the uh the Bell Witch story was uh
what was was a what was fixed was was a
fiction
but it was it was written to be real
historical sounded I think it was
written in the 1800s
yeah which they did that a lot in the
1800s
and the pr some people really believe
that it happened
but it's been debunked because
the dates in which
the people investigating it were there
are given and a date is given for the
time when President Andrew Jackson shows
up to see the good yeah because that's
one of the most famous that's one of the
famous things and that Andrew Jackson
saw and believed it they give the date
for that well on that date he was in
[__] Congress right so no so they
know that he's far away from that from
that place yeah and I think I wrote
about it in my book and we did a show
about it too but and you know my
grandparents were from Tennessee like
were from that area so I grew up always
hearing like the Bell which stories and
they had books about the Bell Witch and
everything like that so I when I was a
kid like you know I loved witches and
anything scary so I always read about
that too I don't know I guess I probably
thought it was real like when I was a
kid but I didn't I guess I didn't really
think too much about it but then like
later on as I was kind of like because I
was figuring oh it's probably just like
a story or maybe it's just like
exaggerated or some [__] that really
happened but I don't even know
I don't even know if any of it happened
I think I don't think a lot of it just
kind of got made up and it I think that
happens like the longer ago it was the
harder it is to kind of suss out
because like you said if you're just
like checking newspapers or something
like that they printed [__] that was
just like fiction all the time
and they didn't really have any
distinction between they could just
print a story that someone just like
literally pulled out their ass
and printed as though it was Trail it
was the only local medium that they had
right and you couldn't check like you
couldn't like cross check it well it was
it also was a uh was a general purpose
medium
um you might live in a small town and
the only social media was that newspaper
right so it had to be news entertainment
storytelling you know it had to be
everything all in one so some of the
stories were and they were just trying
to sell papers it didn't yeah they're
just trying to make money they didn't
really give a shout about a [__] about
like imparting right wisdom or truth
right so it was it was the it was the
[__]
it was the tablet or the cell phone of
the day
I mean that was even before movies
before radio you know so it had to serve
a lot of different purposes and uh
entertaining you and giving you some
science fiction
or some horror and they would do that
yeah because everybody loves that [__]
yeah I mean this when I was like
researching the um you know the weekly
world news they were saying
you know obviously the recurring
characters like batboy and stuff like
that no they don't really know exactly
why batboy just took off so much I guess
just because that collage like the
Photoshop that they did of it was so
great and like so iconic because that's
really eye-catching like that batboy
thing they even have day out on t-shirts
now and everything
so um but normally they said the the
things that make the most impression
um usually like end of the world type
stuff like people love like biblical
prophecies like the world's gonna end
next year because you know how people
love that kind of crap and um says like
people really love that they're like for
some reason for a long time like the
Elvis is alive so like Elvis was having
different adventures and that kind of
stuff and then they kind of like flipped
the script a little bit later on where
they said now like the actual Elvis is
actually dead like because they've been
saying he was alive all this time so it
was very Bubba hotep but um but yeah
like he had faked his death all that
time ago and now he really was dead so
they did do that like Bigfoot stories
Loch Ness monster that kind of stuff but
yeah it does seem like end of the world
scenarios and like biblical kind of
stuff and I here's something and I
actually remember this too and like the
guy mentioned this on YouTube but it not
too long after 9 11.
um I remember seeing I can't believe
they got [__] got away with this but
they had like a photo on the front of
the twin towers and it had like this
somebody had photoshopped like a like a
Satan knee looking face like into the
clouds like into the rubble you know
what I mean and I remember that picture
too and I was like holy [__] that's a
little tasteless but um yeah they
totally did it and they totally got away
with it too and that wasn't that long
after it was only like a week or two
after it happened and
um also they got in trouble for printing
photos of dead Ted Bundy like after he
was executed okay yeah and um they can't
they tried to figure out because that
yeah they got in real hot water over
that like they didn't I don't remember
seeing those photos I remember seeing
the cup they didn't put them on the
cover but um they were just like you
know Ted Bundy like autopsy photos
inside or whatever it was and then like
on the front page like on the inside
they had like actual legit pictures of
his dead ass body and um I think they
traced it back to like somebody that
worked at the morgue I guess it had like
taking pictures of him and like sold it
because like I said they'll buy pictures
if they're good enough if you just have
pictures of like Jesus on toast or
something they don't want that [__]
because like I said they have a bunch of
those already but if you have something
like really crazy or really like I mean
they seem to like not care if it's real
or not like I said they don't
you know and the way the guy was taught
the guy was actually kind of funny and
he was just like
just the way he was talking was funny
he's just like you know
whatever it was it's like we don't we
didn't like fact check anything you
don't obviously because it's like we
just wanted a good story we just wanted
a good picture we just you know so it's
like we didn't care if if [__] was real
or not we just [__] you know hey you
have a picture of like this [__]
thing okay like a severed head talking
or whatever you know what I mean it's
like yeah send it to us I don't know how
much they paid like for them but yeah
there's a long tradition of this that's
probably the way most newspapers were
especially during the 1800s
you're like they're like this
because some there were some cities
where it was more than one new major
newspaper someone was like five of them
and the major headlines of all the
newspapers were slandering the other
newspaper yeah because it was a lot more
competition more between newspapers yeah
were the main there was I read a book
about that like a few years ago and it
was great it was a great book but it was
about that it was about like you know
big cities like Chicago and New York and
stuff like that they had like you know
five six competing newspapers and
newspapers came out like twice a day
back then too sometimes more than that
so especially if there was like a real
lurid crime or something because people
are people and it's like if you have
like some kind of ghastly murder or [__]
like that you know everybody as much as
you might want to moralize about it and
like [__] like that people love to read
about that stuff okay that's just the
way people are and so you would then
you'd have to like compete like the
newspapers would compete it's like oh
can we get pictures of the cut up bodies
and you know they would have like more
and more ghastly headlines they would
just make [__] up if they didn't know
anything they would like you said like
impune the other newspaper like maybe
like all kind of crazy [__] because
there wasn't really any there wasn't any
regulation there wasn't really any there
still kind of isn't yeah I mean people
piss and moan about it nowadays but I
mean I think it was for the most part I
think it was kind of worse back then
because there was really no oversight
well I think a lot of it is just there
wasn't any honor that's what well yeah
that too uh that was the main thing they
knew what the laws were and they would
just beat the [__] out of those laws
yeah you know uh the thing the only
thing was [__] liable and slander
there was nothing anything the yellow
journalism era it wasn't news that's not
why people were buying it it was social
media it'd be like Facebook or Instagram
or [__] and and PornHub all happening
at the same time it's like with with
your Sci-fi channel and your [__] and
[__] shutter you know [__] horror
going on at the same time all in Pages
it was just written there was no visual
entertainment then except maybe like
Opera some stage plays but that wasn't
portable and On Demand you could buy
that paper roll it up and [__] carry
it around and read it while you were
riding in the [__] trolley cars or in
a care in a carriage you know horse and
buggy days
I used to like back in the old days like
before newspapers had photography like
because I you know would look at like a
lot of old papers uh you know from like
old crimes like from the end of the 19th
century and early 20th century and they
didn't a lot of newspapers didn't use
photos so it's like they would have an
artist that would go in there and like
draw these really elaborate like [__]
reconstructions of the crime scenes and
stuff like that and I just thought that
was so cool like and a lot of them like
super lurid well as lurid as you could
get away with for the day you know what
I mean you can't like show too much
people were tough back then they were
they were they were tough back then they
had a high tolerance for uh for for
violence and crime and well they saw a
lot I saw a lot of it and then in their
day-to-day lives in a way that we don't
really most people don't really um have
anymore like at least in this part it
was the Victorian era but they weren't
genteel or
[__] fragile and prostitution was
[__] everywhere and so in crime and
and evidently uh degeneracy was pretty
common yeah especially in big cities
murder was pretty common people got away
with it a lot
um and in real big cities
it's just uh there's a misconception I
guess because the
way people dressed you would think that
they were real it looks very buttoned up
yeah very buttoned up you think that
they would be real
um [__]
morally righteous but no there were a
lot of criminals
scumbags yeah dudes like H.H Holmes you
know who was he was an unusual even for
his time but he was basically fan of the
Opera
um serial killer
they had
you know nowadays you got [__] porn
stars and [__] but they had hookers back
then some of them famous some of them
[__] elevated mentally you know who
were
real smart women they're well connected
with real powerful guys and
making a lot of money and
artistic you know uh other ones are just
just like trash you know Street trash
you know they just they had everything
it was Humanity didn't doesn't change
much
not the same
no matter whatever what era
and it's kind of cyclical
uh it was in a civilization you know and
then like
ancient Rome even though that was two
thousand years ago kind of Compares
pretty favorably technologically with
the 1800s really because Rome had a lot
of Technology Roma's doing certain
things and with Metallurgy that we
couldn't do until the 1920s
especially making things like valves
metal valves that could [__] seal
real well and there was there was some
casting technologies that they had that
we don't still kind of don't understand
how they did it look it looked like a
die forming and [__] injection
molding of [__] hot bronze and brass
they were ahead
far further ahead than you think that
they were and socially they were kind of
like it kind of like today
an ancient Roman would be
could you could bring him to here in the
United States this year right now you
can bring him here in a time machine and
he'd he'd be comfortable he'd know he'd
he'd yeah I always kind of wonder if you
uh theoretically had a time machine and
could go back and get people from
different eras I'm always like who would
um you know catch up the fastest ancient
Roman yeah I'm just probably quicker
than someone from like the Middle Ages I
would imagine Middle Ages they wouldn't
have couldn't handle it but a Ramen
could handle it and I guess it would
depend on the person too like maybe what
social strata they were from yeah Roman
educated middle class and above could
easily somebody that wasn't
somebody didn't believe in Superstition
but was literate understood the basics
of science because the Romans understood
science I kind of feel like if you
mentioned any era and found people like
that then they would be much quicker to
adapt yeah than somebody that was just
like mired and Superstition and someone
from the Greek age you know like
Archimedes you could bring him here he'd
have no problem
yeah I always kind of thought that too
like somebody like Archimedes or even
like not even going back that far as me
like Charles Darwin or somebody like
yeah it's just like they probably I mean
yeah it would be like a learning curve
for sure because that's the thing is
that what I was going to say was that
you know from ancient Rome to the
Victorian era up until the Industrial
Revolution people's day-to-day lives
didn't really change all that much but
then after the Industrial Revolution
like everything changed and so like
especially like past in the past you
know 50 years as [__] even just in the
past 20 years [__] has changed so much
and so quickly that it's like Industrial
Revolution changed everything but this
new information age
that's changing things [__] faster
than I could have ever imagined I
couldn't have imagined internet
back in uh early 90s
yeah it was kind of imagining it 80s no
no way
interestingly some sci-fi writers uh did
Imagine something like it yeah so well I
could have imagined it but I couldn't
have imagined the implications and
changes that it brought that it would
just like touch every touch everything
totally up up up and the economy as we
knew it you know
um
but then there's a brilliant guys Isaac
Newton
you could bring him here he'd probably
understand everything including most of
the physics
because but he wouldn't accept anything
he he would he would not approve of
anything in the modern era he was very
religious
he would end up he'd end up with them
damn puritanical cult somewhere
probably he wouldn't like anybody or
anything he didn't like people of his
era
true yeah some people are just kind of
like curmudently yeah what are you gonna
do
Isaac Newton was a fascinating
dude though
I read it I think it was autistic
um yeah probably nowadays you probably
would call him that well honestly like a
lot of the most brilliant scientists
probably were on the Spectrum somewhere
well like I said those two things
generally go together not always but um
yeah it does tend to go together but
yeah
Zach said imagine being Henry VIII to
modern day you'd make a good show topic
too yeah I think he's on my list
somewhere like I would like to do I
would like to do a show about him as
well uh Mr 88 said Ben Franklin would
acclimate quickly oh yeah big time I
think Ben Franklin would just be like it
probably wouldn't take him long at all
he'd be like oh all right I'm down
imagine what he would come up with with
modern exposure yeah I just I do kind of
feel like
some dudes like that like I said anybody
that
that's why I think scientists people
like that they wouldn't really have that
much of a problem yeah it would probably
be like a culture shock and everything
like that because things are a lot
different but I think they would be much
quicker to adapt because they're used to
I don't know they're just they seem like
they're more open-minded or they're used
to like the way [__] is so it's kind of
like I don't think they'd have that much
of a problem
um let me see somebody I saw something
up here Ben said I loved weekly world
news's uh artists impression pictures
yeah it's just I mean they had so much
funny [__] and I kind of feel like
people get
wrapped up in their headlines which you
know don't get me wrong are hilarious
and are probably like the best part of
it but they had like a bunch of other
they started doing like
um comic strips like later on and I
think one of the most famous things that
they had was I don't remember much about
this because they had like horoscopes
and they said that was a big thing and
advice columns that were like kind of
crazy and [__] like that but they also
had this guy he wasn't in a vice column
but he was like an opinion guy and his
name was Ed anger and he was kind of
like a parody of like a super super like
right wing crazy like Rush Limbaugh or
something and it's like so he would just
he was always mad about something like
in his in his thing like every week and
so he was he hated everything he hated
yoga and he hated women and he hated
immigrants and he hated
um rainforests that was another one like
I think they wrote like a bunch of
people wrote as him you know what I mean
because like over the years
and I think they even like wrote a book
like of all his columns and it was
called something like destroy the
rainforests and do something else I
don't know it was like some like funny
kind of thing but he was like another
kind of popular and I think at one point
too they even started crossbreeding
because I think that was it batboy that
had Ed anger arrested at one point that
might have been in the comics trip
because like I said it got to a point
where weekly world news they had so many
like quote-unquote recurring characters
that they started like mixing it up like
like the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
they would even have like columnists
that weren't real people obviously it
was just like a team of writers like
writing that but it's like then they
would have like their fictional
characters like interacting with this
[__] like doing [__] with it and it
was just like [__] crazy and I think
there was one point too where a bat boy
did it I thought batboy had an affair
with either pilad the alien or maybe it
was the Bigfoot I can't remember now but
they had some kind of like thing going
on too so they had like some kind of
sexual thing but yeah so um but yeah so
as I mentioned I did mention before that
um
that some of the stories that were in
the weekly world news like the jetpack
story like actually were reported as
real
um but some of the stuff in there was
real like I said there was a story about
Hogzilla that was real or that was like
mostly based on a real thing and then
there was
um you know they they talked a lot about
they had a bunch of stories about you
know that guy
um that father amorth or whatever they
just it wasn't he wasn't he's the guy
the Pope's Exorcist right I know they
made a documentary about him but they
did like a lot of stories about that so
it's like it wasn't like
every single story was just like this
crazy Bigfoot in the Loch Ness monster
are in love and they're living on the
moon it was kind of a mix of weird but
true but everything they said everything
was exaggerated though they're like the
all it was all about the headlines yeah
obviously you wanted like the you know
the cover to be like eye-catching and be
like oh man I need to pick that up and
find out what that's all about but it's
like most of the stories like I said
their whole job they would come in every
day the whole team
is he like it was a big company he had
like a lot of employees
and they would come in and just go
through these piles and piles and piles
of newspapers like looking for weird
stories that they could spin into
something you know but he's like some of
the stuff they didn't change all that
much like if there was like a bizarre
story about you know people like I said
getting struck by lightning or like
falling off a cliff and surviving or
something like that like they said they
really liked stories about people that
went through these things and like
survived and it's like so it was a lot
of that kind of stuff and you know huge
fat cats and they really liked um so
there was that that were like realistic
they said another thing they were really
into was like hybrid like animal human
hybrid stories they're like those seem
to be really popular as well so they did
a lot of those like I said because
batboy was the most famous one but they
had you know man go they had all
different kind of ones because people
seem to like those as well but so like I
said
I think I mentioned this on Monday
but I didn't even realize I didn't
realize that Weekly world news and
National Enquirer were the same
there was the same production company
right now National Enquirer they went to
color
they transferred to color printing in
1979. but they still had the old black
and white press that they used to print
it on and they didn't want to waste it
so they said well we'll just start a
whole new publication that's entirely in
black and white and the thing stayed in
black and white the whole entire time
like the inside there was no color so
they just stayed in black and white
until 2007 until they didn't print it
anymore and like I said that kind of
became like part of their aesthetic that
it was just like looked as [__]
cheap and shitty as possible and like I
said they didn't even try now I will
admit that some of the more recent ones
that I saw the Photoshop was a little
bit better but not much not much it
still looks pretty janky like I said I
had I supposed to look good that's what
I mean I kind of feel like yeah they
were rushed because it came out every
week and they said yeah it was like a
big hurry to like to get everything done
but I think that kind of fed into the
whole aesthetic because I had I used to
buy it on occasion if I thought the
headline was funny enough so
like I said I had one I don't think I
have it anymore
but um that said Hitler was a woman on
the front and they also had Abe Lincoln
was a woman uh George Washington was a
woman so that was like another popular
thing where it's like you know X saying
was a woman or was gay or whatever and
then they had a thing too oh one of my
another one I don't think I wrote it
down but there was one story that was
kind of popular that
um that on the Titanic they they called
them gay skeletons
on the Titanic because it was apparently
two Sailors on the Titanic and they were
like in a loving Embrace like when they
died or something like that but I love
that they titled it like gay skeletons
which I thought was like super funny but
um but yeah that was another thing so
the one that I had that said Hitler was
a woman it was clearly just the top half
of a photo of actual Hitler and then
just like the bottom half of a stock
photo of somebody in like a pencil skirt
and pumps and they just kind of like
stuck it together and then like put it
on the [__] cover and I was like it's
a it I mean just the the shittiness of
it was so Brazen that you can't like not
love it because they were just so
committed
to that committed to the [__] to the
[__] that's what I mean and it's like
and I just really like
I don't know that I like that the guy
made the the wrestling analogy
and he's like and I feel like it's
probably like a lot of the same audience
too like people that really like
wrestling would like this he's like and
I'm not saying they believe that the
shit's Trio but he's like it's kind of
like wrestling where it's like you don't
necessarily believe that it's true but
it's still kind of entertaining and
you're sort of watching it anyway you
know what I mean so it's like
so he's like I don't know if the people
buying the [__] you know obviously when
when they were at their Peak it was like
a million people buying it and he's like
I don't think all of those people
believed any of these stories were true
a lot of people were just buying out
ironically like like I was I feel like
buying Mad Magazine right because it was
cheap like I said I think that was only
a quarter or 50 cents or something like
that so it's like if you thought it was
funny I'm like [__] man it's only 50
cents you might as well pick it up and
like read it and it's like kind of a
laugh you know what I mean so there's
that
so yeah so like I said it started in
1979 just as kind of they didn't even
intend anything really they were just
kind of like well National Enquirer was
their kind of like celebrity gossip type
of thing I think they had some did The
National Enquirer didn't they used to
have kind of I don't want to say
paranormal stories they have like
Bigfoot and [__] like that I kind of
feel like National Enquirer after a
while they kind of went just more in a
celebrity Direction celebrities yeah but
so weekly world news just went in a more
like they like I said they hardly print
anything about so when I was a little
kid in the 70s you know going to visit
my grandmother in Mississippi
she would buy
[__] Inquirer all right and I
remember I used to like skimmed through
and I was a little kid just to look at
the pictures all right but I remembered
what the headlines were and it was
um
basically it was uh gossip about who was
sleeping with who and it was always like
people you saw on television like the
television game show hosts you know yeah
uh what Johnny Carson was doing
was he sleeping with this woman is he
sleeping with that woman
and then there'd be some Bigfoot stuff
or something about piranha in the United
States killer bees
um so yeah UFO story every now and then
you know but you you know that the cops
saw the UFO so yeah you had paranormal
in The Inquirer yeah and then Elvis
Elvis you know Elvis cited yeah
somewhere there was a lot of that a lot
of the world news too right yeah
is Elvis still alive
that kind of [__] so no the uh Enquirer
had all this in it just wasn't as Brazen
wasn't as crazy right you know
it was
that but you know person possessed and
you know then there's [__] Jesus on a
toast to that type of [__] they had that
but that was kind of like like on a
quarantine that wasn't the main thing
for Inquirer that was like a uh
funny Sideshow [__] that they would put
in there to keep the old ladies
entertained you know and then I remember
that there was like uh all ads and
offers
like you know cut this out send us
twenty dollars we'll give you this
recipe books or you know seeds that grow
a special plant and [__] like that
[__] that old ladies would would
probably collector's plates ads for
collectors plates Franklin meant [__]
remember that yeah yeah I remember that
my grandmother had all these [__]
Franklin Mint
plates she thought these things were
[__] priceless
she died those [__] all got thrown
out well that's what they told you on
the TV because they told you on [__]
television that those things were worth
something they weren't worth anything
well no it's like they made a whole
bunch of those and they sold them on
they sold them on infomercials yep
anything they sell on infomercials is
gonna be worth anything and anybody who
wanted those things was collecting those
things bought them from that Source they
didn't buy them secondhand or used
you know what I mean and then all the
buyers are dead things are only
collectible when you have buyers
yeah I mean otherwise otherwise it's
just Chuck and I remember that Gone With
the Wind collectors please yeah I
remember seeing the yeah the Scarlett
O'Hara too now my friend had the Wizard
of Oz ones but she just liked them
because they were Wizard of Oz stuff
right now they realized they were pretty
for all I know some of them are worth
something now but back in back in the
90s they weren't worth anything
that's what I mean it's like nothing's
really is nothing's collectible if like
nobody wants this show you know what I'm
saying it's like there's uh there's a
guy a comic book collector a sauce of
thing on him he had
issue number one
of some [__]
comic book but it was from the 30s
and it's [__] worth evidently it was
like a praised hundreds of thousands if
not like millions of dollars but you
can't sell it there's no buyers all the
fans for it are dead
yeah so you just kept you just keep it
weird you know yeah just keep it I mean
or maybe low-key like try to stir up
demand for it there's no demand for it
evidently and the demand is gone because
of all all the fans are now dead
too old
Ben said they got sued in Australia and
had to make clear The Limited plates
were limited to a certain number of
production days where they could knock
out as many as they wanted yeah yeah
yeah see it's like it's all in the
wording yeah all in the wording
and that's the thing it's like well
limited number I'm like well limited
number could mean anything they would do
the same [__] with those [__] any
numbers limited if you think about it
commemorative Infinity commemorative
course yeah I remember those yeah I
remember yeah
yeah Ben is uh talking about that Ed
anger column he said yeah that was great
and that yeah that was the thing that he
said I'm Pig biting man that's what he
always said at the beginning and he said
there was a crazy woman columnist too
can't remember her name well there was
some advice columnist there was one
called dear Dottie
I kind of remember that one but I don't
know if that was the one you're talking
about Ben said there was a story about
David koresh back when he was Vernon
Howell and had had a shootout with the
previous head of the church oh yeah [__]
and then Ben said I remember when Bill
Clinton was accused of having an affair
with one of the aliens who was visiting
the White House for secret talks here I
remember that too then Hillary got back
at him by having an affair with an alien
too that's what yeah
that's what happens Hillary was mad that
like he got the three breasted intern
and also banged an alien was like well
I'm also gonna bang an alien and see how
you like it Hugo said were there more
newspapers like this one
but the thing about it is like there
were other tabloids for sure yeah like
the sun which was kind of like their
main competitor but none of them were
quite as
trashy as this none of them were quite I
don't know I can't quite put my finger
on it this is the Jerry Springer of
newspapers and this one went crazier and
it really didn't care if the stories
were believable or not I mean
it just it went straight up paranormal
it just went you know it was [__] about
ghosts and like I said the Loch Ness
monster and but they're joking about him
right but well not really because they
were just they would write everything as
though it was real like they very much
tried to keep everything like straight
faced as though it was a real news story
even though they were clearly just
making [__] up well there's the ghost
story right there was that they did an
autopsy on a ghost that's obviously I
guess that's [__] great I mean like I
said I didn't see what the details are
were they doing an autopsy on a guy and
a ghost and he came back alive
and then died again so is that
he was like a ghost see that might be
true because like I said I mean the guy
that was the editor from 1999 when the
new owner took over whose name was
pecker by the way David pecker which I
remember because of course I'm gonna
remember that but um James you never
forget the Packers I never forget the
pecker I never forget a pecker but oh
yeah that's another t-shirt I never
forget a pecker Jenny but um yeah this
is the money court right there but yeah
so he was saying now like he said he's
like I did make some stories up just out
of whole cloth so he's like so I'm not
saying that but he's like most of the
stuff did happen the idea came from
somewhere like it did have a germ of
Truth in it in a newspaper story that
whether the original newspaper story was
true or not we don't know but he's like
we did usually get the ideas from there
so as I was saying before about him
writing a headline that was like you
know alien sexually assaulted by
dolphins or whatever it was he's like
obviously it wasn't an alien and they
weren't but it was about that one like
the story that she had told him about
getting
almost raped by a porpoise while she was
like working on a movie so he's like so
that was the story that she told me but
I just like made it seem like a lot more
so I kind of feel like maybe
that was probably the origin of that
like maybe somebody did come back to
life while they were being autopsied and
so somebody read that and said oh I have
an idea uh we'll make the headline uh
you know we're autopsying a ghost
because you know what I mean so I kind
of feel like that was the mindset that
they had that was the impression that I
got like from listening to him talk was
that they would try to take everything
and like kind of twist it to sound as
outlandish as possible but then when you
read the story it didn't sound quite so
crazy because you know they were just
trying to get you to read the [__] you
know what I mean so
so yeah so uh so like I said they had a
bunch of kind of like recurring stuff
batboy being their most famous which as
Oracle mentioned was actually turned
into an Off-Broadway musical uh by
actually I think it was Tim Robbins uh
acting group like they did once again I
haven't seen it but I've she said it was
crazy
um that was in the 90s that was 1997.
and so yeah so ever since 1992 like when
batboy first came out of the scene
um you know they put him all through all
kinds of Adventures like he was always
he always had like this group of
scientists like trying to capture him
and stuff and he would always like get
away from them and
then he went on to like [__] uh uh he
was I think he bit Santa Claus at one
point too like so there was that
um he like endorsed some presidential
candidates and he um helped capture
Saddam Hussein there was that
um see what I mean and so like I said
they even like expanded it out into like
a comic strip later on
um where he was like in love with a
Bigfoot or a half Bigfoot or something I
can't really remember what it was and I
think he was even like in a death metal
band too or some [__] like that so it's
it just went in like crazy [__]
directions like I said this has to be
the way the guy talked about it
um he's like a lot of the people that
worked there like when he was working
there like had been working there for a
really long time
um and he didn't seem like I mean I
guess he wasn't having a good time
because it wasn't really his back but
um I just I don't know I thought it
would sound like kind of like a fun job
yeah it'd be like a lot of Rush and a
lot of pressure and everything because
you know when I've worked for newspapers
a lot so it's like I kind of know that
how that goes but I mean just sitting
around in a writing room looking at
crazy stories and like making crazy [__]
up and like the crazier the better I
mean that kind of sounds fun to me I
don't know I mean there's worse jobs for
sure
um and then another thing that he said
too is like you always he's like
whenever you wrote a story no matter
what it was about
he's like you always had to have an
expert and he's like it didn't matter
who the expert was he's like hell I was
the expert sometimes you just needed
like a really good he's like or somebody
else in the office he's like you just
needed somebody to like give a good
quote and it's like they're the expert
blah blah and then they would make the
name up
um you also had a scientist she's like
if you didn't have an expert you had to
have a scientist or as the Wikipedia
page points out it's like um you either
had a scientist or a baffled scientist
there was that too so that was that was
like another thing
I can't understand how this man found
this tiny mermaid in this tuna sandwich
um and also for a time I didn't remember
this because I don't know if they had
stopped doing this by the time I bought
some but you know how in um I can't
remember what British paper it is but
where they had the the page three girl
um I get the weekly world news had a
similar thing except they called it the
page five honey so they always had like
but she wasn't new because in the UK you
can show tits so um in the in the paper
so they would always have like a topless
woman on page three of whatever
newspaper it was that I can't remember
the mirror of the sun I can't remember
and um so they couldn't do that here but
it was just like a girl in a bikini or
something like that like big boobs but
um they stopped doing that like in 2006
though so yeah so they did um you know
again like a bunch of Elvis's alive
stories they're like it wasn't just
Elvis either like a lot of times they
would do
other kind of [__] that shouldn't be
alive like a dinosaur or
um another like a caveman like one that
like Encino Man or something that had
been like Frozen in a block of ice I
think one time too they said they found
Santa Claus in a block of ice so that
was another story that they did
um they also wanted to do uh you know
and it also wasn't just Elvis like they
would do like you know JFK is alive or
Marilyn Monroe is alive or people like
that Michael Jackson and Hitler or
people like that
um and there was a lot of stories like I
said there was ones about
the Titanic uh they had a run with not
just the gay skeletons on the Titanic
but they had ones where they went down
to the Titanic and found survivors on
there including babies so so that was
another that was another story so um
that was another one that I thought
they'd been down there for 70 years or
something like that right yeah which is
that's and babies and babies so I don't
know if this is yeah that's what I was
yeah I was like does that mean like the
survivors were like [__] down there
like having babies like down
they're eating each other like they're
they're eating their feet like in
Survivor type that Stephen King's Story
um but yeah so there was all of that and
then like I said they also had kind of
an obsession with
um
it's usually like fat people or fat
people or Fat Cats because like I said
the world's fattest cat whose name was
Tanya
um they did a whole thing with that cat
doing all kind of like adventures and
like I said I think that cat was I don't
think she was quite as big as they tried
to make her seem maybe but she was like
a hugely fat cat so that like people
responded really well to that story so
they kept having this big fat cat like
doing other things you know what I mean
it's like she would have like I said she
had 23 old ladies you know just an
inversion of the whole cat lady thing
with lady with 23 cats so they did that
and then they had like that big huge fat
guy who got lowered into the thing and
then
well the funny thing about the cat was
they had all this kind of stuff where
um the cat had to go on a diet and of
course she went on the catkins diet you
know what I mean and um then she got
anorexia so that was another story where
the fat cat got anorexia and then there
was a story where the world's thinnest
woman had eaten her so there was that
too eating the cat eating the cat yeah
so today was that
um but yeah so they kind of had a thing
about about fat people too and they said
another thing that was real big was
um like as any kind of like apocalyptic
or Armageddon type scenarios and like
especially like upcoming depressions
like um economic depressions they're
like people loved those for some reason
so they would always run stories about
like oh the banks are gonna crash like
next week and you know everybody's gonna
go broke and it's gonna be a whole it's
going to be a new like Great Depression
and all that so they would always print
that kind of stuff too
because that was really popular
um and then there was like
stuff about
um you know there'd be like this whole
like everybody'd be starving and there'd
be like a plague and looting and all
that kind of stuff and then like I said
they um another big thing that they
would do too was like any kind of like
religious stories biblical stories Jesus
in the clouds devil in the clouds
um you know holes to hell that I
remember seeing a bunch of those they'd
be like um
there was a lot of stories about the
Garden of Eden I remember seeing what a
like Garden of Eden found uh yeah at
least according to the lore they said it
was in Colorado so yeah makes sense
which the Mormons would say yeah well
yeah they're like well we would say Utah
but you know close enough
um so they'd have like
you know God gave we found more
Commandments like that kind of thing
um you know found Noah's Ark that was
another I wonder what the Commandments
were yeah I don't know why did Noah's
Ark yeah that's an old one yeah I kind
of feel like that still well and the
thing I've been wanting to do a show for
a while on like a mount era rat biblical
archeology yeah because there's all kind
of crazy rabbit holes to go down
um in that field let's call it that
um but yeah like search for Noah's Ark
all that kind of [__] it's fascinating
actually even [__] Leonard Nimoy on
in search I was talking about
did a whole show on search for Noah's
Ark
and then uh they were always bringing up
Mount error rat yeah that there was
something up there
he had a photograph it looked like it
might be the ark there's nothing there
though
Tammy says they turned into mermaids the
Titanic survivors
then Ben said they used to have helpful
tips to spot people who were really
aliens in Disguise yeah that was another
thing that they did oh and they had a
thing too that I saw about how to spot
someone who was a Satanist so that's
nice yeah
um I have a book like that like written
by a Evangelical yeah Christian and I
was just like well guess I'm a Satanist
so you know what I mean it was all the
regular [__] yeah they wear black hair
yeah they have black hair black they
have a pentagram they're listening to
heavy metal or yeah and so you have a
Judas Priest album some of the [__] was
weird like even like peace signs and
stuff like that were like signs of
Satanism I'm like since when are they
gonna try to put the hippie movement in
yeah they're like yeah we don't like
hippies
yeah yeah so it's that kind of thing
so um as you might imagine like after 9
11 there was a bunch of stories about uh
terrorism and that kind of stuff
um a lot of stories about Kim Jong-il
like taking over the US
um Saddam Hussein like them finding a
cache of secret weapons but they were
dumb weapons like giant slingshots and
and then and dinosaurs like he had
dinosaurs that he was hiding so there
was that yeah so like I said it's like
they're just taking [__] they're just
making it silly you know what I mean
it's like yeah we totally found [__]
dinosaurs and then um they had a thing
too like they had a couple stories about
how Saddam Hussein and Osama Bin Laden
were going to get married there was that
yeah
um that Adolf Hitler had been cloned and
was going to join Al Qaeda so there was
that too
um and then Saddam Hussein who was
captured by batboy
um okay and you know he led the charge
yeah like in case you didn't know I mean
now you know the truth comes out
um yeah but yeah Saddam got uh he won
the lottery apparently like in the U.S
and uh asked for the government to pay
for his sex change operation so there
was that
um and I think I mentioned earlier that
another thing they would do a lot of
stories about like so and so historical
figure was a woman
like George Washington or Abe Lincoln or
whatever and they also did a like a
long-running thing about how the
founding fathers were gay there was that
yeah that was like back in the 90s I
think or 2000s and um oh one of my
favorite ones too was that Dick Cheney
was a robot which I was like well that
explains a lot but uh yeah and uh also
that George W Bush was having an affair
with Janet Reno okay there was that too
which like I said I kind of feel like
even though
they didn't do quote-unquote celebrity
stories but they did talk a lot about
political figures and so I always kind
of wondered because some of the stuff
they printed I mean obviously you said
like oh you know Bill Clinton has like
it's [__] an alien it's like nobody
that like duh like obviously that's not
real but it's like if you were saying
stuff about like Affairs between like
actual people
um I always wondered how they got around
that because he said that they had a
whole
Quonset hut of lawyers they'd be like
yeah you can't print that because they
were afraid they get sued but it's like
because they they couch it and I guess
some sources say that
our sources say that that yeah it's like
we're not saying yeah we're just saying
somebody told us about that right and
we're just repeating that information
yeah yeah that's how you cover your end
that's how they cut well see and I feel
like performance tell us that happens a
lot like so well you always kind of have
to watch because when people give you
information about something they're just
like oh well some are saying this upload
some who yeah who is saying that yeah
like you know give me a name give me
somewhere I can get it from because if
you're saying some is saying that I'm
like that could be anybody or that could
be nobody that could be that could be
you saying that if you're saying that is
is what that is usually nobody they're
making it up yeah it's like you're just
making it up yeah and well and it
technically like I said it's not untrue
because they say well some are saying
that I'm saying it I'm saying it right
now so it's like some are saying it yeah
you know it's not a lie yeah you just
have a lot some [__]
somebody says nobody likes you that's
he's that's the same as saying I don't
like you
speaking for everybody else
yeah I mean pretty much one of the
[__] psychopath [__] ways to do it
pretty much yeah well it's kind of a way
of you just want to get your opinion out
there but without but you're putting
yourself at one room it's like well I'm
not yeah saying this we're all saying
this other people are saying it I kind
of feel like that's the same kind of
thing you know those kind of
[__] that always like they
they'll say something really shitty and
then they'll say something like oh well
it's like well everyone was thinking it
I was just the only one with balls
enough to say it I'm like yeah no
actually no one was thinking that you
were thinking that yeah and you just
wanted to say it out loud and couch it
in terms that made you feel like you
weren't like a [__] [__] but yeah
that's I you know I'm not falling for
that I'm just saying I see that a lot
will you stop [__] with me what's
Pookie doing she's try to get attention
yeah okay
she's on the show she's like I'm not
looking over there I'm not looking over
there I'm not looking over there she
just just wants attention yeah she
doesn't like it when we like do the show
because she's like you're not paying
attention yeah so um yeah so like I said
they did a lot of alien stuff too
they had one repeating alien character
whose name was um Altair Bob
and he apparently uh contacted the
weekly world news
through quote unquote Bob is Balter yeah
Baltar that's from [__] Battle Star
Galactica yeah that's this he contacted
the paper through quote unquote
telepathic email okay which it's an
email that comes through his mind he
doesn't need a computer well then why
did you why would you even need to tag
email onto them why can't you just say
telepathy
since that's like mine to mind why do
you even need to like say telepathic
that's not even the thing no because it
shows that doesn't make any sense it
shows up but he doesn't have to send it
but he doesn't have to send it he just
sends it with his mind but functionally
it doesn't really matter like if Elon
Musk is trying to make that happen now
because you don't know that he said it
with his mind it's just like you gotta
email like a regular email and you're
like what do you do I'm sending this to
you through mental email that's what I
mean they can tell you whatever [__]
I didn't even sit down and type this I
just thought it just thought it and then
I sent it to you and I'm just like okay
it's the world news weekly
we got another mental [__] email
that's telepathy email from Baltar
yeah they know I guess but yeah he told
him all kind of stuff he said you know
there's other aliens not me but other
aliens who've been like um dumping all
their garbage on the moon so you might
want to do something about that yeah
um also bringing people back from the
dead
um fighting Bigfoot because you know
there's a whole alien Bigfoot crossover
thing when did that happen I don't know
that's another show we need to do
because I'm very curious about how the
Bigfoot thing and the Extraterrestrial
thing got cross-wired like when did that
happen
when dudes were trying to make [__]
material for their podcasts and for
their [__] little shows they have to
somehow
get [__] as as many fans as possible
together you know right on One show
they're trying to integrate so they're
trying to integrate
but yeah so we we got invited to this is
in the early days of this show
we got invited on other shows to be his
guests and we didn't take them remember
that one it was and it was like that the
supernatural bigfoots yeah yeah yeah I
remember that show we never did we never
did do that I think we did a show like
that but it's like I don't know if
anybody listened to it or yeah because
after a while like look what I'll sit
around and [__] about aliens or
[__] about Bigfoot all day long but
it's like the second you start telling
me that the reason that they haven't
found Bigfoot is because oh by the way
he's an interdimensional being yeah that
I'm just kind of like I'm just gonna
back away slowly yeah you know what I
mean it's like no no no judgment I'm
just saying
there's some the internet the
interdimensional Bigfoot is that that
they they came up with that as an
explanation as to why they no longer
find any footprints
right you used to find Footprints
because they had dudes hoax in them
okay yeah well the footprints hoax the
the footprint hoaxer is gone
people are seeing Bigfoot no Footprints
though to prove it
so I said well it's because he [__]
went through a dimensional door
yeah so it doesn't I'd love to know the
first American person to come up with
that
I mean it was kind of a brilliant idea
and like people took it and ran with it
even though it's clearly the most the
stupidest thing ever became part of the
[__] lore yeah so now there's a way
to do that though there's a whole subset
of Bigfoot people that actually do
believe that he's like not even an
animal well they say well the Indians
say he's more of a spirit
okay so now they're going the Native
Americans yeah yes that's what it is he
he's an interdimensional being he's not
a he's not an he's not a Native American
Spirit the Native Americans knew about
him but what he really is is a [__] an
alien kind of a thing that comes through
a dimensional door every now and then
yeah he forges
walks through the woods every now and
then walk through the woods and
everything hell don't you didn't see me
that he's gone you know he makes no
sense it makes no [__] sense it
really doesn't it's like I don't under
like look why why would a Bigfoot do
that even an interdimensional Bigfoot
you would think that they have would
have better things to do Bigfoot stories
go way back they do yeah um president
Teddy Roosevelt
basically told a big a Bigfoot story
that they were around a campfire
and they heard some animal-like noises
and something big man-like was out just
out of sight they could barely see it
and it threw a rock and it landed in the
near the fire
and um they all had the guns at the
ready because looking Teddy was the
[__] he was a good Hunter ex-soldier
and [__] and then the [__] thing ran
off and then he heard like a a wild
[__] howl you know and
I I don't believe he saw it okay I think
it was a tall tale
uh men were supposed to tell Tales back
then you know like a campfire tail
basically yeah I mean that was kind of
like part of the day you had all your
buddies over you had some Sherry or some
Brandy yeah some cigars around the fire
and it was like hey tell us a story like
entertain us they didn't have TV yeah so
he didn't say anything about Bigfoot I'm
not sure Bigfoot was a thing
but it probably was I think guys like
guys like Teddy who was a hunter and a
soldier probably would have been like on
The Cutting Edge
of the
you know because he was you know he's
big into nature camping and [__] he's
the kind of guy that would have heard
early Bigfoot stories
they would probably wear Native American
so I think he just told a Bigfoot story
what I'm saying yeah probably yeah he
didn't see Bigfoot he didn't see
anything about Footprints he said it was
man like and big
he can see a silhouette and it had a
wild howl and it threw a rock
but I think he's I think he heard a
Bigfoot story and repeated it or or made
his own Bigfoot story
yeah I mean that's the thing very early
1900s yeah and like you said because
prior to the Advent of television and
the internet and things like that people
entertained each other by like sitting
around telling stories yeah and things
that were like Legends yeah Mysteries
that was like Prime [__] right yeah
everybody loves that [__] yeah still and
Teddy had a [__] killer a killer
reputation so if he told this story
people would be like oh wow that's a
wild [__] you know what I mean because
he was
Woodsman and Hunter and Soldier he was
actually a war hero war hero really he
actually did some [__] against fought
the Spanish I believe
on one of those islands
um
so if in his day he was kind of a badass
for a politician
he's the kind of guy that would tell a
Bigfoot story
hell yeah he does seem like something he
didn't do that yeah and I mean even if
he did see something or somebody out
there it's like he would just exaggerate
it exactly a dramatic effect which might
have been a Native American throwing a
[__] rock at him yeah it's like hey
piss off [__] out here white man because
I saw it I don't know what it was it may
have been the Skookum
[Laughter]
or the Florida skunky yeah although
we've already established that Tom is
actually the Florida yeah yeah
especially after certain meals
[Laughter]
yeah every now and then well we had
talked about like this was a while back
but we were talking about making like a
skunky video because I wanted Tom to be
the skunky yeah because that's what I
call him sometimes it was going to be an
obvious hoax though yeah we were just
gonna have fun with it we weren't gonna
like try and fool anybody we just
thought it would be funny like for Tom
to be the skunk ape yeah we should do it
I don't know if we could do a whole show
about the skunk ape yeah because he's
just kind of like I think we well we did
this show about Cryptids yeah and I
think we did the Cryptids show we talked
about like all the different because
it's basically just like a Bigfoot
variation so I feel like after a while
that's like really not that interesting
it's like yeah it's like a big man-like
ape-like thingy that's like wandering
around in different environments there's
no Bigfoot
not in North America
if anything like that existed it'd be
somewhere in Canada
and I don't think I don't think it
exists I don't think there's I don't
think the uh
it's not the right it's not the right
climate it's not the right
the only thing is like a Bigfoot that
might exist would be like the orang pen
deck where is that from uh Indonesia or
no uh
where was that
I forgot what country it is but there's
something called an O-ring pen deck
and uh an anthropologist saw it or a
zoologist saw it says yeah so it was a
woman she she saw it she says it was
she said it was a bipedal ape it wasn't
a [__] hominid though
which like I said if in in the great
course of all of the quote unquote
paranormal topics yeah
you know Bigfoot and aliens
are more believable than some of the
other [__]
like I'm still not saying they're super
believable but I'm just saying that on
the spectrum of believability they're
closer to the spectrum of believability
yeah unbelievability I used to think
there's there could be a Loch Ness
monster but no
if you look at the bottom of Loch Ness
there's no food not enough food there
for something that size and if there's
one of those things then there's a bunch
of them there's a whole breeding
population
and you would see them if there's a
breeding population of the surface hang
it out like elephants would like I said
it's a Loch Ness monster maybe that's
another reason why Bigfoot has gone the
interdimensional being route because if
it was just an animal then why would it
hide necessarily like it wouldn't no
like the Loch Ness monster wouldn't have
any concept that it was this mysterious
creature it would just lay out on the
[__] beach yeah sun in itself you
know
the young would be up to surface playing
yeah it wouldn't really feel any need to
hide from anybody especially at that
size and there'd have to be a viable
breeding population so there wouldn't be
inbreeding which means maybe 20 30 of
them you just couldn't hide big animals
20 or 30 big animals like that in Loch
Ness there's not enough food in there
the water's cold
there's no not any vegetation really on
the bottom
just no
it's deep and it's cold
it's not the right place for something
like that not a food there
Tammy says Sam Elliott killed Bigfoot
and Hitler a good movie yeah that's
right I've been wanting to see that
actually that um yeah it's called the
man who killed Hitler and then Bigfoot
or something like that Tyler the guy
says never seen a picture of Bigfoot
that wasn't grainy as [__] yeah I mean
that's kind of the thing and it's just
kind of like all of the pictures that
you see of like UFOs and [__] like that
they're all shitty it's like look
everybody has
an HD camera in their pocket pretty much
nowadays if that [__] was around
somebody would get a good picture of it
but the thing about it is that now it's
so easy to fake [__] that if you did see
a really good one then you would just
immediately suspect it was fake so it's
kind of like a no-win situation what I
think is funny is that right now they
got a guy who's verified
high level security clearance guy
and um
I don't remember what agency's with he's
on the news right now saying that yeah
we have alien retrieved alien craft so I
just saw something about that earlier
and nobody's given it any play or any
attention the guys I saw a headline
about it on I don't remember what it was
just like on my it's fine my news thing
yeah he said I don't and he didn't say
he saw him though
or at least not that I right I want to
hear his whole story
but yeah he might just be a repeating
second might be repeating what he heard
which is not
but nobody's really paid any attention
to it
might have been something distractions
aliens yawn we got aliens and nobody
gives a [__] about you that's [__]
funny I mean until they like show up in
the [__] driveway yeah I'm kind of
like man whatever you know what I mean I
want to see the [__] I want to see the
[__] so yeah I talked about pretty sure
they're coming here
um
some of those reports are real
they're not all real though and uh
there's no telling what it is maybe one
day we'll figure it out
I don't think they're going to talk to
us I don't think they're really I don't
think they're [__] interested in us
we're not we're not impressive there's
there's [__] like us everywhere I guess
that's what I mean it's like if I was an
alien why the [__] would I come here
yeah we're boring I think they just come
by and check and go yeah they're still
here look at those little [__] down
there
let's wipe them out no I don't think
they're by wait we can't wipe them out I
don't think they're biological I think
when you see the ship I think that's
them
that's it
I know but I like to think of them like
little Grays and they like talking to
each other about like just blowing our
planet up what we know now it's unlikely
that they're by that their biology
they're and they have to like stop each
other for days like I'm gonna push the
button I'm gonna push it but don't push
the button Carl God damn it I just kind
of like picture that I don't know why
but yeah so
uh pilad remember I said he was the
alien that was having an affair with
Hillary Clinton apparently he was like
real into like female politicians all
around because he also him and Hillary
Clinton broke up I guess and then he
went after Condoleezza race so you know
yeah
um also Hillary Clinton later adopted an
alien baby so that was that too
um so and like I said there was a big
thing and I think I had the um I think I
had the issue that had the alien
endorsing Clinton for president like in
1992 or whenever it was I think I had
this so so they every time there was a
presidential election they would always
have it was pretty much like the same
picture of the alien like shaking hands
with whoever the
the favorite presidential candidate was
so they always had that like every
single time
um let's see let's I'm trying to think
of like I'm trying to look at some other
stuff that they had so yeah we were
talking about Cryptids
um you know they had half Hannibal half
human hybrids mer people that was a big
thing half alligator half human
kangaroo half woman half kangaroo
um Bigfoot steals race car that was yeah
it is cool I mean like like you do like
I said a lot of mermaids
um you know there's a lot of mermaid
stories like in the early 2000s remember
I mentioned earlier that the whole
jetpack thing like got reported as
legitimate another one that got reported
as legitimate which again you know just
isn't as crazy as some of the stuff was
um all the stories about Facebook
shutting down
like that there was a lot of stories in
like 2012 I feel like was like oh my God
Facebook is going to shut down and ever
since like that and that never that
wasn't true that actually came from the
weekly world news but it did get
reported as Trail uh in various like
news sources and stuff like that so as I
mentioned uh weekly world news
was
um their print version went from 1979
until
2007. I think their Peak was 90s like at
their Peak their circulation was like
1.2 million which is quite a lot for
like a weekly newspaper and like I said
I kind of feel like most people were
just buying it for shits and giggles I
don't think people actually well I'm
sure there was a percentage of people
that did actually believe some of the
[__]
but most people were just like buying it
as a gag like I was
um but then after that you know in the
2000s you know all print media was
going downhill
um you know people weren't buying it as
much so in 2007 they decided they were
gonna uh wrap it up so they went online
only and so it's still they still have a
website like I said it's behind a
paywall but um you can read three
articles for free and then they make you
subscribe but last year or a couple
years ago they actually started
um doing like
like a company it's like weekly world
news like Productions or something like
that so I guess they're gonna start
going like multimedia so I don't know if
they're gonna start making I think they
do have a YouTube channel I think but
it's like so they have like little
stories on there and there's like a lot
of YouTube channels that have like their
old commercials because they used to run
commercials on TV and stuff which is
crazy but um I don't know if they want
to like
make movies or like which would be great
I think they should like make some
[__] movies about some of those
stories because they would be [__]
that'd be [__] hilarious but uh but
yeah I especially want to see second
pope under Pope hat I would have watched
that movie
well who's that other pope then who's
the little that's the
[Music]
well see that's that you know as you get
the little ones it's the little one and
he's like Whispering too see it's like
there's a whole scenario like I said you
can make which one's the real Pope
some of the some of the headlines that
they have
you could make a whole movie out of that
because of all the questions that it
raises like you said like with the
second pope under the pope hat who is
that that's like the secret Pope he's
the one actually like running the world
he's like the head of the Illuminati or
whatever the [__] and it's like the
first poke though well I know I don't
either but I'm just saying I'm just
saying I'm just like yeah I didn't think
that was funny necessarily because I
cared about the pope but I was just kind
of like it just tickled me to think that
he just had this little dude like
sitting on his head like under his hat
all the time I'm like where does he poop
is he just like pooping on that dude's
head or does he have a chamber pot or
what see like so many questions so many
questions that it raises and like I said
severed like hops to hospital I would
watch that movie too even though it's
kind of not a whole movie that's really
more of a vignette but okay
um but yeah so uh do you have anything
else that you would no that's it like to
say that's it bro uh Ben said have you
said anything about the crowdfunded
website version from about 10 years ago
oh yeah I didn't mention that yeah they
did actually do a Kickstarter and uh
and they actually like got all the money
so yeah they did actually uh end up
doing that but yeah
um Ben said that's the black Pope the
head of the Jesuits the anti-popes are
rival Catholics who claim to be the real
Pope yeah that's right but that's
another show we should do that might be
interesting too yeah I've been hearing
about that but I don't know anything
about it yeah yeah
a lot of the uh New World Order
conspiracy guys will take it into the
damn Catholic realm between the Jesuits
and the and the and and the Catholics
and it's a secret War happening with
them it's like something out of the damn
video game I don't know anything about
it though Yeah just something that just
keeps coming up I mean well see that's
the thing look I know that people
and you know they they always have this
is part of the human condition people
love mysteries and people love
um
how how can I put this people like for
there to be intention and meaning behind
things even when there's not especially
when there's not so I kind of feel like
that's what fuels a lot of
conspiracy type stuff I think it makes
people feel better to think that there's
like some big Shady organization it's
running things running things rather
than [__] just being random because if
shit's random then bad [__] could happen
to you even though you're a good person
and that and people don't like thinking
that people like to think that there's
some kind of cosmic Justice or something
like that and there's not so it's like
so they like to think that there's some
kind of intention even if it's negative
intention I've noticed even if it's
malevolent they would rather that than
everything just being random [__] like
[__] just being random really seems to
upset people yeah all right here's my
take on it
a lot of people this is just this is
just kind of across the board
see
the world is a is a hierarchy and that
above them is something else and above
them is something else and above them is
something else if you go to the top
there's somebody in charge like Oz was
like right yeah that there's one person
some shady organization that controls
the nations of the earth and blah blah
and then they the then there's
corporations and everything that's
actually not how it is you got to look
at the world more like the jungle
all these organizations are just animals
in the jungle they're all fighting for
their own Survival
uh sometimes they'll pair up with other
animals to knock out a third animal
that's their enemy there isn't any clear
hierarchy especially when you start
getting into like corporations and ngos
they're just an animal in the jungle
all right they have their own powers but
they're usually limited to just one of
the things that they do and they don't
have the ability to say like apply Force
they can just an army of lawyers maybe
they have that and some money
so they can do a couple things real well
but they can't do everything
every organization is like that
including corporations Corporation can
seem to like have a lot of power like
Disney
can seem to have a lot of power because
they can make movies and they can piss a
lot of people off if people don't like
the movies
but they're not all powerful they're
[__] going down in flames right now
my words my sources say
Disney's gonna sell off a couple theme
parks overseas and they're gonna sell
they're in talks right now to sell
lucasfilm back to George Lucas
because they're going broke
their their liquidity is only like 400
million dollars and that's nothing
compared to their debts and all their
overheads so Disney
will be lucky to survive this
and that's starting to come out today
but uh
my sources are good so yeah that's
happening and it's they're going to
blame all kinds of [__] well you know
Florida did it to him no
there was a big
they hid a bunch of money that they lost
um
I guess it's been about six years ago
and that's coming to light and some
people got fired over that
allegedly okay
and then um
Disney did a bunch of [__] to itself
over the years it couldn't it couldn't
catch back up its theme park is getting
its ass kicked by it's basically getting
its ass kicked by Universal
although I tell you what my sister was
just at the Disney parks this past
weekend and she said the [__] was
[__] packed did you okay and actually
when I was there last time it was
[__] packed yeah well the problem was
is that they made a bunch of movies and
then they had their own streaming
services Disney plus and they lost their
asses on that there's billions of
billions of dollars
and then uh that was the problem it's
not the theme parks the parks did pretty
good it's all the money that they
[__] lost on that damn Disney Plus
they should have never tried to
have their own platform and compete
against [__] huge [__] Studios
they've been better if they just give
put that [__] out on Netflix
speaking of streaming Wars speaking of
predictions I thought this I only just
remember this because you're making
predictions about stuff but when I was
listening to that guy who was the editor
of the weekly world news for a while
yeah I guess this interview was from
when was that whole
um Will Smith slap thing what did that
happen oh that's about a year ago I
don't remember but um whenever that was
so this must have been like right after
that because they were talking about it
so um they were talking about how
um you know oh all the movies like you
can't piss off China now because that's
like a huge uh market and bloody blah
and so one of them said like the guy
said oh well Keanu Reeves said something
to piss off China I don't remember what
it was
um and so he'll never make a big budget
movie again and I was like
well the thing is wrong it what doesn't
matter China doesn't matter anymore
um because they don't really they really
don't watch any American stuff anymore
like it was there's been like a
revivalist of Chinese patriotism and
they don't like foreign [__] and they
don't like the United States
so it doesn't matter and Joker came out
and [__] kicked ass and it didn't I
don't think China even got it China
didn't get Joker
um and what was that a billion something
dollars one of the most important yeah
of all times a few billion dollars and
yeah and it didn't cost anything to make
uh just because she goes to show you how
ex how much money you can make off of
just good storytelling and great acting
yeah I mean [__] Masterpiece you
don't need yeah CGI CGI and a bunch of
you know you don't need all that like I
know a lot of people like that like in
spectacle and stuff but it's just like
you don't need that necessarily yeah if
you have good storytelling and good
characters and [__] like that yeah you
can still make money my prediction is
that
George Lucas is going to buy that back
and you'll still get Mandalorian and
you'll get some of the other stuff that
was his name Favreau was doing I think
his name
I think John Provo is going to be on
that team
uh the word is that Lucas liked the
Mandalorian
a lot of other [__] he didn't like he
didn't like those movies either
side
I thought I heard that he liked uh
uh Rogue one
he liked that one I also liked it yeah I
thought Rogan was good
I mean even though I thought it was the
solo was mediocre it wasn't bad it was
kind of mediocre well the thing about
Rogue one is like even though you knew
how it was gonna end pretty much but
they still managed to make it like
suspenseful and compelling and stuff the
Han Solo movie was okay but I kind of
feel like it was too much of a oh and
this is how this happened and this is
how like it seemed a little episodic
right
um you know it was an okay movie it was
entertaining but it just seemed like
they were it was too much fan service
and like not enough and force awakens
came out came out and I liked it I
thought they were gonna set something up
I thought it was gonna go somewhere
the Ryan Johnson movie came out [__]
oh no it just blew it for me and then
that third one came out
it it had to be it was a [__] show but a
lot of the [__] show was trying to save
what happened and [__] the last and
what was it
in the Ryan Johnson when I remember what
that was so they tried to repair some of
the damage there it was just you don't
make a Trilogy and use different
directors on each one of them and
[__] you don't have a story arc
planned out they were making it up as
they were going along as [__] obvious
well it's just [__] terrible that's
like I said I didn't mind I'm I can't
believe you're still talking about it
after all this time but it's just kind
of like because I've just oh man I
really forgot I used to love Star Wars I
used to love it I liked the Mandalorian
of the first two seasons I haven't seen
season three I've heard mixed things on
it but
um and that hurts because a bunch of
[__] got cut out because they didn't
have the cast that they were supposed to
have when they first planned it because
there was going to be a bunch of stuff a
bunch of Gina Carano stuff in there it
was going to link up with another series
that she was going to be in
having to do with the damn I don't know
some kind of star Pilots or some [__]
but we'll see I think if Lucas gets it
back he'll probably save it because
they'll retcon a lot of that [__] and I
think a lot of fans will come back and
the next step to do after that be to fix
Star Trek
although I heard that [__] the one
with Pike in it supposed to be pretty
good
looking thing is called uh strange new
worlds I think is what it's called It's
supposed to be pretty good but I haven't
seen it I'm not going to get CBS to see
it I don't give a [__]
they need to sell that [__] all a cart
I'm not into this platform streaming
well I mean that's the thing I just kind
of like
in some ways you can kind of see most of
what you want to see a la carte like I
said if you have a couple streaming
services or like you know we have Amazon
Prime but you still have to like rent
stuff on there but you can rent almost
anything you want to rent on there but
then there's some stuff that's just like
Netflix exclusive or or is Disney Plus
or something like that and yeah you
can't see it which is kind of a pain in
the ass but the thing about it is that
there's so much material there's so many
movies there's so many series that I
want to see but it's just like I don't
have time to watch them all as much as I
might want to so it's like I'm not gonna
pay look we already pay for Amazon Prime
We already pay for Netflix I already
paid for shutter uh I pay for Hulu and I
pay for HBO Max
and it's like 98 of everything I want to
see is on there so it's like and if
there's something that's not on there
then I might just like order the [__]
Blu-ray off of Amazon or for 10 bucks or
something like that you know what I mean
just to keep from having to subscribe to
another thing
and it's weird because back in the old
days I remember when we first got cable
because we had it pretty early because
my dad used to work for the cable
company back in the early 80s when it
was very new
and we always just to say this even back
in the even back in the day when we only
had like you know 40 50 60 channels and
we thought that was like a million uh
because we're like holy [__] because we
were used to growing up with like three
or four channels and it's like look it's
like why can't we just have you know MTV
HBO you know whatever like a couple
other channels it's like look I don't
need the [__] PTL Club I don't need
Home Shopping Network I don't need any
of that stuff I don't watch it so it's
like why can't I just have like five
channels I do watch and just pay for
that so now it's more like that but in a
way it's kind of going back to the old
where they're kind of like making you do
like a package thing yeah
but in a way that's more spread out
because it's like now it's like well you
want to see this series well you have to
pay for this whole other streaming
service and I know it's not expensive
but they do add up
you know
I don't know Ben said that uh season
three of mandalorian's great yeah okay
I mean I really like the Mandalorian I
haven't seen season three
I got season one on Blu-ray yeah I
ordered it I don't know how that
happened I got it off [__] eBay yeah
it's a bootleg but it looks Factory
yeah it looks like it came right from
Disney
yeah it's I'd like to get season two and
three like that yeah because I ain't
gonna get Disney Plus for that [__]
well like I said well the thing about it
now is that
um now you can get a bundle with Hulu
yeah which I already have Hulu and I
think for like and I already pay like I
think it's nine dollars for it
um I think for like a buck more you can
get Disney plus also like bundled with
Hulu yeah so I mean if you want me to do
that I will because I already pay for
Hulu so yeah and then we could I like
Hulu because they have all the all the
Gordon Ramsay shows and they have
handmaid's tale watch season three and
then cut it off yeah that's true
um but actually I would just I'd like to
have those on Blu-ray I like to have
hard copies of [__] series and that's
I didn't see Disney doing that I didn't
see them selling
Blu-rays which that's a whole potential
Market yeah that's a whole potential
Market yeah they want people they wanted
people on that Disney plus right I get
it and they were trying to like force
people into it but honestly I think it's
better because nowadays people are just
used to having options yeah so you know
what I mean and even like the big movie
studios have seen that nowadays it's
like look we're gonna put the movie out
in the theater but we're also gonna put
it out on streaming so if you don't want
to go to the theater you can watch it at
home
um you know for the same price or
whatever which like I said that's a good
compromise because some people went John
Wick three and four I need those on
Blu-Ray so it's like so I don't
understand like why you would cut off
like a large source of potential Revenue
by saying oh we're not going to put out
like you know hard copies or we're not
going to put this on another streaming
service when it's like a lot of people
would probably pay for that you know
what I mean yeah a lot of people would
probably buy it because they're like
well I don't want to pay for another
streaming service but I do want to see
this one show or this one movie and I
would actually pay for that one thing
you know so you should just have that
option available you would think I don't
know
uh yeah Ben said season three is a
subplot with X Imperials being paroled
into the new Republic and being up to no
good also there's a really cool space
pirate who looks like Oscar the Grouch
oh okay see I'm kind of into that and
then Zach said still can't wait to hear
y'all's thoughts on the last of us we
still we we only watched like the first
couple episodes yeah we haven't like I
haven't got back it wasn't compelling to
me I didn't I really didn't care what
was going to happen next
um plus I got distracted by watching
yeah uh
Bates Motel because I got because Celtic
Angels yeah for some reason that was not
an addictive series to me you know like
walking dead you see you see episode one
you have to see episode two and three
and four and five it pulls you right in
but this one this one uh Last of Us I
thought was slow
and kind of uninteresting
but that's the thing you always kind of
have to
I mean series I'm willing to give them
like a few episodes because I know in
some series it takes a while to kind of
you know get into the groove or whatever
but yeah all right so uh I guess we'll
wrap it up because yeah I got [__] I
gotta do I gotta go to bed soon yeah uh
because it's getting to be kind of late
so yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed this
rambling discussion about weekly world
news and yeah it was just a fun episode
various other things yeah like I said it
was kind of nice to do one that was just
kind of like silly and not about
depressing topics which is nice uh but
yeah so we'll be back Friday night for
the side track show so hopefully you
guys can all make it for that so thank
you everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us this evening and
we'll see you guys again on Friday night
good